so what if you pray five times a day so
what if you give x amount of uh
sadaqah so what if you pray x amount of
nothing
actually we need to humble ourselves and
remind ourselves that us
praying that many times a day us giving
said amount
ask praying extra salawat that in itself
is a blessing from allah in the first
place by having instilled it
in our mind to want to do it yeah
we need to thank allah not just for
being able to give
we need to thank him for having given us
the consciousness
to want to give in the first place
because even that is from him
[Music]
a lot of people have this misconception
that uh you know once i feel closer to
god then i'm gonna start practicing
it's backwards you won't feel close to
god until you start practicing the
prophet i said
there's a hadith where he says that the
most beloved acts of worship to god are
those which he made obligatory the
person continues to get closer and
closer to allah
key point gets closer and closer by
voluntary acts of good so like certain
things you know for the sake of allah
things that are not obligatory but you
do them just to please allah
until allah begins to love the person so
two things you want to feel close to
allah you want allah to love you
do what allah prescribes for you which
is
so praying
giving extra charity to the point where
allah will insha allah begin to love you
and welcome back to the readers podcast
in the dunya the three muslims podcast
if you like what you're watching then
inshallah check out our other episodes
like comment and subscribe and check out
our patreon insha allah
for today's episode we have another very
special guest brother
mahdi salamu alaikum how
of course so today we decided to talk
about something we didn't really talk
too much about on the show up until now
which is basically
finances entrepreneurship and we know
you have a very specific background in
all this you know having run businesses
yourself
um so we want to get into that inshallah
so do you mind giving us a bit of your
background
in the business world sure well i mean i
don't consider myself a business expert
let me just
put that disclaimer out there um but let
me just let's back it up a bit so
my my adult life started pretty young i
got married at 16 years old
and i left home pretty much straight
away to live with my wife
and our child that was on the way so as
soon as we got married she fell pregnant
a couple months
literally six weeks later and then so
she's a stay-at-home mom i had my first
we had our first kid at
17 second at 18 third at 19. when i was
20
one of our children passed away when i
was 22 we had another one when i was 23
we had another one
so it was really like it was it was i
was forced to grow up from a very young
age i had to
because i decided to get married so
young and just as a disclaimer for the
audience it was not an arranged marriage
no i met this sister
in in school in college and we liked
each other and we said we said we want
to do this the
way what's the point in messing around i
saw the sister was wearing hijab
and i always had this thing even though
i was in my jahiliyyah
i always had this thing where it's like
you don't mess around with the muslim
sisters
i know that sounds bad but it's like the
muslim sisters
if you want to deal with a muslim sister
deal with her seriously
so we decided to get married and allah
facilitated that with ease alhamdulillah
so we got married she had we had a bunch
of kids
she stayed at home i went to university
and i did the whole university thing
i graduated from university in 20
2013 and then immediately i headed out
to saudi arabia because
the whole time whilst i was in
university i was doing a degree
sports and exercise science that i
realized
towards the end of it that i don't even
enjoy this topic
i like sports from a perspective of
participating in them
but i don't like actually studying
the science behind sports and if you've
done a sports science degree or you know
anyone who has
don't be fooled by the term sports it's
basically
a science degree and i don't really like
science
so i ended up doing a course that i
don't really like
anyway i finished the degree
alhamdulillah got towards the end of it
and i started looking at my options what
do i do now where do i go next
and it just so happened at that time
that a lot of brothers were heading over
to saudi arabia
to teach english so i said to myself you
know what
that makes sense i can live in a muslim
country i can earn good tax-free money
my kids can you know be raised in a
muslim environment this sounds like it
makes sense it was better than my
options
that i had here in the uk so i did a
celta
i flew over to saudi arabia and i lived
in medina for a year
the idea was i spend one year on my own
saving some money
establishing ourselves and then i bring
my family over the following year
of course allah had different plans so i
spent that year in saudi arabia
got towards the end of the academic year
all the teachers were assessed
and there was a big school jamiatriba in
madina it's a big university
and alhamdulillah i got the second best
uh assessment out of all of the teachers
in that
in in that that in that school at that
time
two or three weeks later i was fired so
i go from getting
the second best grade to being fired
immediately afterwards
and when i look back on it in hindsight
i realized why
certain aspects about my character i was
a bit too assertive with um
the upper echelon if you like in voicing
my views and so on but what it made me
realize was that
even as a good performing teacher as a
high-performing
employee i was still disposable and the
only way i can explain it was
i felt like a tissue paper i was sneezed
into
they had used me now it's time to throw
it in the bin
and that's the reality as an employee
especially as an employee
who wasn't very highly qualified let's
face it most people have a degree today
and a selter is not really a big deal so
i hadn't really differentiated myself
very much so i spoke to the brothers
before i left and i said to me maddie
look
you're not highly qualified enough you
need to get a master's degree
so that you can um you know bolster your
your cv your credentials and then come
back again and apply because now you'll
be
less disposable if you like so i said
okay
that makes sense i made some money i
thought i'll come back to the uk
and i'll do a master's degree in english
language
i signed up for the master's degree in
english language it's 5 000
i saved enough money to be able to pay
for it and before you pay for the degree
you get this
six week block where you can basically
trial it to
see if it's for you i started the degree
the master's degree
i hated it i hated every minute of every
minute of it
after that i was introduced this to this
uh to this concept
this new opportunity if you like it was
called acn i don't know if you guys have
heard of that it's a network marketing
company it's from the us
i was introduced to it and basically
long story short
it said it's like your your classic
network marketing company
no different and i was intrigued by the
opportunity of being able to
work for myself that was the dream that
was sold right work on your own terms
work for yourself and so on
so i'm four weeks now into the master's
degree
this opportunity acn has been presented
to me
and then i had a real i came to a real
fork in the road
and i said to myself matty are you going
to continue this master's degree
that you hate only so that you can then
get another job that you also hate
that doesn't make any sense you're going
to pay 5 000
to do a degree that you don't enjoy so
that you can then get a job that you
don't enjoy
that doesn't make any sense so
i decided to pull the plug and and quit
the master's degree and
that was a big decision for me at that
time that was like i realized
the course of my life is changing
direction now in a big way because
my whole family everyone's highly
educated my sister's doing her phd right
now
and everyone's got a good job and a good
solid career
and establish themselves in their
respective field so for me to pull the
plug
on on that life that came as a shock to
my family
and that was like that wasn't an easy
decision for me to make because i
realized once i do this there's
i can't come back to this now call us so
i put i quit the degree i said enough is
enough i'm not going to work for
anyone anymore i poured my heart into
acn
and it was initially a success it was
going well it was going all right
and i was making respectable money not
millions but good enough
six months later i realized there were
certain
shadowy issues with the business model
that i was no longer comfortable with
and i decided i don't want anything to
do with this business
so i quit acn six months later
now i i was married
with four kids and no job
completely broke okay so it was a quite
an embarrassing situation for me because
first i had hyped up this whole acn
thing to my family
and then i had quit it and on top of
that i had quit my masters which means i
had
no backup plan none whatsoever
so what do i do next i got four kids to
feed and a wife and
and i've got no money what's my next
move then i remembered whilst i was in
saudi arabia
i came across this one particular
product that
was very effective at dealing with
treating eczema
particularly in kids but for for all
people adults and children alike
and i thought to myself why don't i try
and sell this product in the uk it was
effective for my family my friends loved
it everyone's asking me where do i where
do i get it from
why don't i just try and sell this thing
myself so i bought
i bought some on that cream and the way
i did it was the individuals who had
tried the cream already i said to them
look guys
you like this cream right okay but i
don't have money to buy more of it
if you want this cream tell me how much
you want
give me the money up front i'll go and
buy it and then i'll bring it to you
so i had my retail price and i had the
cost price
and i charged them the retail price so i
took that money i told them up front
this is the deal
i don't have the money to get it but if
you give me this money i can get it for
you
sort of like some type of weird type of
drop shipping thing
i did that and i think we managed to
collect just 800 pound nothing much
took that money bought the cream it was
enough for me to buy a substantial
amount to start the business
and then we're off the races after the
races from there literally three months
later
that business was turning over 20 000 a
month online
through minimal marketing minimal
marketing and so panel
is like i want to really make it clear
at this point this is not because i was
some type of genius
did you know there are elements in
business where they call it luck i call
it
i was fortunate to have found a product
that was good
that was in demand that the people
wanted and that they were willing to pay
a premium for
period that was it and i took i took
advantage of it
i saw an opportunity i took it i took
the opportunity
three months later i'm earning money i
had never seen before i'd never
seen that type of money in my life only
twenty thousand pound a month
and here's the problem once you start
earning money
that you've never seen before you start
to
think this is the new normal
and it's not you think this is the new
normal and slowly but surely
i started taking my foot off the gas
pedal i was no longer doing the same
making the same adverts putting the same
work into the copywriting
the same marketing efforts the ad budget
i stopped doing that
and it was a slow process i initially
like took my foot off a little bit
and then i took it off more and more and
more until the business was literally
running itself but here's the scary
thing
i wasn't doing anything to for the
business and yet the business was still
generating the same revenue now i said
to myself that's it i'm set for life
this is it this business is like a gold
mine i don't need to do anything
and the business runs itself very
dangerous
never ever think for a moment that with
no effort your business will continue to
maintain
because there is no such thing as
maintenance you're either growing
or you're shrinking and there's nothing
in between
so i stopped putting in that work now
eventually there was like a delayed
effect
have you ever driven a car that's got a
turbo when you put your foot down
initially you hear the turbo revving up
goes and then
there's a lag period right i was in that
lag period where i was doing no work
and the business was still making the
same amount of money
after that lag period had passed slowly
slowly the numbers started dwindling
but what had happened to me i had become
a bit
lazy fat as in my my motivation muscles
were fat
the money came too easily and i said to
myself okay
if it decreases by two thousand a month
that's not a problem eighteen thousand
pound a month is still okay
sixteen thousand pound amount is still
okay fourteen thousand pound a month is
still okay
and slowly slowly the numbers continue
to dwindle and i continue to justify
my laziness that's the bottom line
until eventually we're talking now two
and a half years later
it literally took two and a half three
years that's how solid the product was
it took nearly three years
for the business to reach a point where
if i didn't do something
now right now i'm gonna be in big
trouble all over again
so the business went from twenty
thousand pound a month all the way down
to
i remember the lowest was 2 200
gross not net which means the profit was
negligible on that
and it was in that moment it was in or
march 2019 i believe it was that i
decided no maddy
this is ridiculous now we need to do
something about this
so at that time the business was on
facebook i decided the new market was on
instagram
all the kids are on instagram i wasn't
particularly familiar with how instagram
worked at that time but i thought
let's just try it put the product on
instagram i just did the same things
that i was doing on facebook i would
collect
customer testimonials from the customers
before and after pictures
a few sentences of their experience of
the product
and then just put that out there put it
online and see how the people react
and again to cut a long story short
march 2019 the business was generating
i think it was three thousand pound a
month at that time
fast forward to june 2019
and we had a 49 000 pound month that
month so it went from
3 grand to 49 grand in a very short
space of
time once again this time i said to
myself i'm not making that mistake again
okay i've got the business to hear i'm
not taking my foot off the pedal this
time
so i started you know developing systems
um
hiring outsourcing work such as the
media work
the advertising and so on and i really
wanted to make something bigger this
business
at the same time i started siphoning off
some of the profits of the business
to invest in other ventures because that
first experience i had before
of the business going from 20 grand to
three grand a month that was scary
i didn't want to go through that again
so i said this time i've learnt my
lesson
i'm going to invest in other things and
at the same time invest in building this
business
so the business continues to build and
it's going well all is going well
december 2019
six o'clock in the morning i had just
prayed salah
all of a sudden i hear bang bang bang
bang bang
it's the police open up bang bang bang
open the door we're gonna break it down
now just to give the context i just
prayed i was lying down on the floor
in the lounge half asleep i was
completely disoriented
i went to the door and i said to them
how do i know you're not you're not
burglars
i was disoriented they said if you don't
open the door we're going to break it
down i said show me your badge through
the letterbox
so they put their their badge through
the letterbox i saw the badge
i said okay clearly these guys are the
real deal they came in
there was about seven or eight of them
swarmed my home
like mosquitoes they went everywhere i
still don't know what they're here for
at this point
like i was my mind was going everywhere
am i being caught on some type of being
done for some type of terror charge or
what why are you
what are you here for they sit me down
and they say to me
we've been informed that you're selling
an unlicensed medication in the uk
you don't have a license to sell this
product and i said to them are you
referring to my excellent product
they said yes this is a licensed product
and you don't have the right to sell
this product here in the uk you need a
license we need to go for a bonafide
like it's a whole big thing they
confiscated all of
the um all of the product that i had in
the property in the home
they shut down my shopify store shut
down my website
shut down my social media channels in
one go i don't even know how they did it
it was a complete shutdown instantly
immediately they shut it down and
so from that after that day i literally
went from having a thriving successful
business
to nothing overnight just like that but
alhamdulillah
this time i had already made some
investments elsewhere
and saved a little bit of money as well
so that i could plan my next moves give
myself a bit of time
before moving forward onto the next
venture
um so that's the story of how i got into
entrepreneurship basically and since
then
i've been dabbling with different things
and i have continually made a dua to
allah
i make this made this down all the time
i don't want to live this
life just functioning just earning for
the sake of it
i want to find my purpose you hear you
know entrepreneurs talking about this
all the time
what's your life's purpose what's your
what are you here for and aside from
worshiping allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
what unique gifts and skills and
abilities and passions do you have
that you can benefit the world this has
been something that's been very very
important to me
and i have been willing to turn down
some really good opportunities for the
sake of
finding and then once i found continuing
upon
my purpose and i've i believe i've
recently found alhamdulillah
in the whole you know masculinity field
bringing back masculine muslim men
but yeah so that's basically my story i
also wrote a book on my experiences of
taking a business from three to thirty
nine k in 121 days that books actually
on amazon
it can be bought there and that's that's
essentially my experience in business
i'm sure i've missed a few things i've
had some other ventures as well
that i've papered over there was another
arthritis product that we were selling
there was another
sexual performance product that we were
selling a couple of different things
that i've dabbled with
over the years so that's basically my
journey in entrepreneurship
mashallah
no i got so much to say man i know bro
so many points that i could relate to
but
you go first bro because you got like 10
minutes yes so
first thing man when you said the whole
thing about um
studying the exercise science um bro
i was doing the same thing the same
exact thing that you said well i was
like yo
i like sports like participating in them
i don't i don't really like like this
whole studying thing like it's not
really sports
and like bro alhamdulillah bro i swear
that's why i do martial arts and that's
why i want to get into
you know having my own gym having
multiple gyms and all that but
man like that that touched home for me
and wrote the fact of like you
saying that you started something you
started making a lot of money
and then you got comfortable you took
your foot off the gas and then it's like
there was a delay
bro like i had the same exact experience
bro fire bro please go i would like to
know what was your experience
man so i have a youtube channel aside
from this one
all right and the youtube channel i had
about like
i wanna say after like two something
years
i had like maybe seven to ten thousand
subscribers
alhamdulillah but then like i had
basically started to really research
more into like how to make viral content
how to really like blow the channel up
and well i kid you not like by the grace
of allah
within a few months i went from seven to
ten thousand subscribers to like over
150
000 subscribers and it's like it kept
going it kept going it got over 200
something
thousand and then i got comfortable and
it's like bro
like i'm not gonna sit here and and say
like the amount that i was making but
let's just say
that it it was it was a delay
and then this just declined and there
was this constant rationalization of
like ah
well this is enough and you know what i
have this free time that i can do this
this and that
but it's like dude as men like we don't
really want free time
we want something that we can devote
ourselves to absolutely
you know so like for the whole time that
i was doing that and i kept
rationalizing this like
bro i asked myself the same question
that you asked yourself it was like
what is my purpose here besides
you know i'm a new muslim i'm a reaver
so like
now i understand okay our true purpose
is to worship allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala but aside from that
like what is the thing that we can
devote our time to our energy to what
can we
what was going to be our craft in this
world in this dunya
and bro like i was doing youtube and i
was like whoa youtube isn't it like
i love helping people i love sharing my
experience and all that
but like this this isn't my craft i
can't say it is because you see other
youtubers and
and you know it's their crowd because
the amount of work that they put in
like the editing and just the quality of
the videos you're just like wow
like this is beautiful and i remember
one day
like long story short man i had gotten
into the gym
and i started doing some uh some muay
thai my friend was showing me the muay
thai
and bro man it felt like time just stood
still
but my mind was completely quiet and i
just felt so at peace i was like you
know what
i could devote my time to this i could
devote every single minute of every
single day
to this now i'm not going to do that
because obviously you know we have to
pray we have to do all these things we
have to
keep that taqwa but like i can devote
most of my time to it and as these two
brothers here
like when we're not in ramadan like bro
i'm training like
over 10 hours a day in martial arts
yeah it is bro but it i love it
it's like bro how much hours you put
into your work
more than 10 hours a day i bet no
absolutely yeah
yeah it was kind of low man a lot of
similarities that i've seen
i love the point that he brought up
about comfort man you're either
progressing or you're regressing there's
no in between
facts i mean
sports has been a big part of my life
for all of my life
and i can connect that particular point
to sport in particular in sport
you are either improving or you're
regressing there is
no such thing as maintenance you know
when people say oh bro i'm just
maintaining
no bro there's no maintaining think of a
seesaw
you have a seesaw right the seesaw is
generally balanced in the middle
but it's never actually reaching total
equilibrium it's always moving ever so
slightly this way or that
same thing goes with your body same
thing goes with your mind same thing
goes with your business
it is either growing or it's regressing
and shrinking there is nothing in
between
and there's a great book that i read
that connects to that topic well
and it's by the founder of the intel
chips i can't remember his name but the
book is called only the paranoid survive
brilliant book by the founder of intel
and i forget his name
and he talks about the importance of
always staying
paranoid in business and you can take
that mindset to anything
let's say you're a champion ufc fighter
or a boxer or
you're in business it doesn't matter
there's always another
hungry wolf climbing that hill snapping
at your heels
someone who is who's not full yet they
haven't tasted that type of success
they're hungry you've got to constantly
stay in shape
you've got to constantly stay paranoid
when it comes to your business
looking at the different variables
analyzing the numbers breaking it down
and striving to continually move forward
i would say even with the dean
even with our religion we can become
comfortable you know alhamdulillah
brother i pray
i pray five times a day you know okay
masha'allah that's good
you're cutting the basics but are you
progressing
because if you're not progressing you're
regressing
somewhere else somewhere else in in your
iman
it's regressing you might not even be
aware of it just as in your business
there could be areas that are shrinking
and regressing that you might not even
be aware of
but it's happening because we are not
operating from a point of paranoia
i know it has a negative connotation
that word but i
like the title of that book only the
paranoid survive
and better to be paranoid than to be
lazy and off the ball
if i had to choose between two i'm going
to choose paranoia
it's like obsession my bad bro go ahead
i was just gonna say um
so would you then say that the idea of
maintenance is
just um like the lag period afterwards
how do you mean so like for example for
you
you thought you would maintain that
business because it was it would
maintain itself
and you were deluded by the fact that it
didn't initially drop
down there was a lag before it did so
i'm asking the idea of maintenance
would you then say that it's just you
perceiving the lag but not knowing it's
it's lag well i would say it's you
you're not aware of the lag in the first
place
let me give you another example you've
got a big steam train and it's traveling
down at
i don't know 150 kilometers per hour
okay suddenly you cut the power
there's no power five seconds later if
the train was traveling at 150
kilometers per hour before you cut the
power
precisely five seconds later what's the
speed of the train
probably the same or very close probably
the same exactly
that's that's the lag time you see in
business maybe that five seconds will
extend to five months
maybe even five years who knows
everyone's lag time is different
and the the really dangerous thing is
the longer the lag time the more diluted
you become
i had quite a long lag time it was a
good few months
until anything started changing but i
cut the power
at this time and it took a few months
for the train to start slowing down but
the problem is
once the train starts slowing down it is
so hard to get it going again
if you've ever watched world strongest
man one of the events they have
is the plane pull they put a plane or
they'll pull
two big buses right the hardest part
of that event is the star always
and they always talk about the
commentators the importance of
keep your momentum going don't let the
thing
stop because the moment it stops you
have to apply
all that force to break inertia all over
again
to get that momentum right and momentum
is a cruel mistress i remember hearing
this once on
some video i can't remember now it's a
cruel mistress it can turn on you very
quickly
the moment you take your eye off the
ball you cut the power
the train is beginning to slow down it's
just that initially there's a lag time
and you can't perceive it
and that's dangerous because you think
everything's fine
that's exactly what happened to me
another beautiful example
tommy have you ever you ever done a
handstand
i tried have you ever felt like the uh
the shift in your body weight as you go
into
like that middle point yeah if you feel
the shift in your hands it's the same
thing you're talking about like
where you're never just like fully
balanced you're constantly
twitching back and forth and then bro
it's like the moment where like you
might be
leaning too far to one side that's the
lag time where you don't perceive it
and by the time you perceive it it's
like you have to really like
both brace your core to be able to like
bring yourself back
or it's a little too late and then you
just fall down
that is such a good example that is a
great example i can do a handstand i
know exactly what you're talking about
when you're dead straight it's okay you
can feel yourself moving a little bit
but if you don't catch it quick enough
you're finished you have to
straight all you've got is finished
exactly exactly though
man that reminds me of uh a couple years
ago i was in really
i was the leanest i've ever been in my
life and i finally got lean and i
thought okay cool
call us like i can maintain this now
right so what did i do stop working out
started eating like
trash and i'm not gonna lie that like
period you're talking about it wasn't
as apparent because it took me a year
and a half to finally start putting on
weight
why maybe because i've been in the gym
very consistently before that
but once i started falling back it took
me a year and a half to notice
and then i was gaining weight and then
it was very hard for me to get that
inertia going
sex yeah amazing it's able to be a
universal law you can apply it to
literally anything
you're you're the quran your
memorization of the quran
or your memorization of anything for
that matter your studies your
position as a ceo in a company anything
literally anything it's a universal law
maintenance is a myth write it on your
wall look at it every single morning
maintenance is a myth it doesn't exist
it honestly it reminds me like when you
said that it applies to
dean as well because when i first
reverted like my mind was
obviously very strong and i was learning
the prayers and doing all this stuff but
it's like once i learned
the prayers i literally took my foot off
the gas
and i was like all right well i know the
prayers let me let me focus on the
prayers let me you know
kind of just do my thing here and like
you said there was a life period and
it it wasn't evident to me until closing
in on ramadan where i was like
one day i was just so turbulent like so
upset about something i was like
dude look at yourself like look how far
away you are
from the straight path from the demon
like yes you do the martial arts yes
you're on your purse it's masha allah
but like your deen is so weak your mind
is so weak because you've
literally just decided like oh well now
i know this let me just kind of ease up
and not do anything
um the scholars they talk about um
knowledge and implementation and it's a
constant cycle of knowledge and
implementation
um for example you have to take the
action to learn knowledge
and then once you have the knowledge you
have to implement it into action and
then it just keeps cycling and cycling
so there should be no point in your life
where
you're not either learning something or
implementing that thing that you learned
or teaching it matters
and as a muslim no excuse to not stay
busy
just for the deen itself but with
working everything as a high value man
yeah
i would say i mean as as a muslim and as
a man period
you know especially as men the burden i
mean this takes us on to a whole
different discussion but the burden of
performance is upon us as men
and i appreciate sometimes it takes time
uh for you to make these realizations
especially if you've been used to
something that came very easily as in my
case with the business for example
my first experience of entrepreneurship
of business
was very easy and that lulled me into a
false sense of security so it took my
business to nearly go out of business
for me to actually wake up and realize
hold on a minute i need to pattern up
but also as as uh
just said it's not even about the money
or about being secure
as men it's about constantly moving
forward
to the next goal you never arrive there
is no arrival
there's a goal and if it's a lofty goal
you might never reach it
but if you do that's okay pat yourself
in the back for a couple of days
and then reset and move forward again
because and this is a known fact
many most many people who retire in
their old age
die a few years later very few a few
years later from the day they retired
to the day they died there's only a few
years in between why
because whilst they were at work they
had something to focus on
their mind was continually being
stimulated they had something to work
towards
even if it was not their purpose so to
speak it was still a goal that they had
to work towards i need to teach this
student
or i need to finish this project
something the moment the mind becomes
stagnate
you stagnate with it and it's almost as
though the body says
well if there's no reason for you to be
here we may as well not be here
and then you're gone you know so yeah
constantly moving towards the next goal
especially as men
jesus man
because this is like this is a real
combo here bro for real
but um you've heard of beginners look
yes i'm glad you brought it up yeah bro
i'm i'm
literally i've come to realize that it's
not
luck like you said it's it's allah
but it's it's like allah is like
blessing you with something where it's
like you're starting this new venture
and allah is like blessing you with like
look this is what you can
achieve this is what you can do but then
he strips it away to test you to see
like okay i gave this to you you know
what you're capable of
now are you gonna put in the work like
do you really want it let's see how bad
you want
absolutely absolutely i can't remember
the exact words but
um there's a fable in 48 laws of power
that refers to this
about when something is meant a path is
meant for you to
to traverse to walk to travel on
you will experience initial easy success
exactly what you're talking about this
whole concept of beginner's luck
but then it will be taken away from you
now you have the memory of what success
felt like but now you're locked in you
might be going through this down
period but you're locked in because you
know okay you know what i had that easy
that that easy time there but now i'm
locked in i need to continue and
actually make something real out of this
so yeah absolutely
bro i'm gonna let you say your salams
before i go in
all right nice to meet you i look
forward to speaking to you again in
charlotte yes
brother yes same way yeah right that's
what i say
i'll see you all in the next one take
care oh thank you mr ambrose
man couple things going through my mind
i was watching a highlight of yours on
ig one night
and it had to do with mental health and
now i know this is extensively
a topic that deserves an episode of its
own but without going too much you were
speaking on some gems about
why in quarantine or the lockdown people
were kind of regressing in their mental
health or they they had all these things
like depression
and and you gave a very unconventional
approach to
it right so do you want to go a little
bit into that yeah i think you're
referring to
what uh the works of viktor frankl in
his book and search for meaning
so again this is not my i'm not a mental
health specialist
i know very little about mental health
for that matter but i am regurgitating
parroting what i learned from that book
and viktor frankl he is a holocaust
survivor
and if you read that book by the way i'm
not going to lie to you that book made
me cry i read that book twice
maybe cried twice it's deep subhanallah
what
type of hardship man can be exposed to
and still come out of it it's it's
amazing you i
i can't do it justice by trying to
describe it but anyway
in his book he talks about how
much of our mental health issues don't
stem or don't originate from too much
pressure
they originate from not enough pressure
and he gives the example of a bridge
engineers
when they see that the structural
integrity of a bridge is weak
do you know how they strengthen it they
take a load a weight
and they put this weight on top of the
bridge
to to strengthen the uh to sort of like
push
okay think of a sand castle you ever
been to the beach before
you've got your bucket and you make a
sand castle right suddenly you see the
sand castle starts to crumble what do
you do
instinctively you put your hand on top
of it
to pat it together again you apply
pressure
same with the bridge when the structural
integrity of a bridge and i'm no
engineer but i'm just again
parroting what i learned from the book
when it's compromised engineers place a
weight a load
on top of the bridge to strengthen its
foundations again
he said equally with the mind often you
will find that people's mental health
issues
originate less from too much pressure
and more from not enough pressure
and what you were referring to for about
lockdown is the reason why i brought
that up
particularly in lockdown i kept on
seeing mental health posts coming up
over and over
and i made that connection i i said to
myself well maybe there's a connection
here between
people being laid off work temporarily
and now all of a sudden they don't have
the pressure of
work which they thought was bad for them
but actually
just like the sand castle just like the
bridge it was keeping them mentally
stable
and the moment that pressure was removed
from them that's when things started
falling apart
it's steven right your thoughts around
me because you're going into engineering
said again i was i was asking ramy to
give his thoughts because he's going
into engineering
it's uh it's honestly profound that's
that's crazy i never thought about it
like that's fine a lot and that's
something i witnessed myself which is
why
it hits so close to home for me because
um i was locked up for a long time and i
witnessed you know my own kind of like
mental decline
um not that it was you know horrible
alhamdulillah but it was noticeable for
me
when he's talking about locked up he's
not talking about prison all right he's
talking about like just
coin thing yes yes uh thank you for the
clarification
yeah and then did i start working again
more recently and it made me feel
you know like a man again and made me
feel good again
um not that it gave me purpose
alhamdulillah but it
kind of put me back on track
alhamdulillah i'm that in the deen
learning islam and everything
alhamdulillah so
i'm not an engineer yet so i can't
really comment uh too much on it but um
i imagine that they put enough pressure
for enough period of time
and then remove the load um because
obviously too much pressure is
you know too much pressure like people
suffer from ptsd and certain things so
obviously
no one over burden themselves and cause
trauma in your life but
the point is that this whole idea of you
know this life can be like jannah
nothing bad you don't want that because
if you had that then
your life would suck and it's kind of
paradoxical
um but a lot is very true um i guess
i'm beginning to realize more and more
that everything is about balance like
literally
everything in life is about balance um
and not that everything needs to be in
the middle but it needs to be balanced
um meaning if this side is light and
this side is heavy
and maybe you need to be a bit more
towards this end just balance it
properly
moderate everything and subhanallah i
think this is another
great example so i think that was really
profound
i mean on that point of balance i will i
will contend something different i will
say to you there will be periods in your
life
where you need to be very unbalanced and
then other periods where you need to
pull back
and focus on a different area i'll tell
you what i mean
if if we are aspiring to be high value
men
it means as a high value man you need to
devote a certain amount of time on a
daily basis to
set courts for example angela was saying
um
he often devotes up to 10 hours a day to
his martial arts right that's not
balance
that's completely unbalanced but it's
the price of success
in said field it's the pa the price of
progress is the price of excellence
that's what it costs
excellent has a cost so there will be
times when you need to be extremely
unbalanced
in order to make progress and then you
need to pull it back
and give attention to those other areas
of your life where you may have
neglected
during that period of imbalance when you
are pursuing
said cause yeah yeah yeah i understand
what he's saying that that does make
sense
um i think i think the difference would
be our understanding of what's being
balanced
for example if you were to take how much
on hill spends a day
in terms of hours and balance it with
everything else it would be unbalanced
because you're comparing
how much time he spends training how
much time he spends everything else but
if you were to compare something like
um how long he's training and how long
how much his body can handle
um maybe it's balanced maybe it's more
balanced but in in your case i
definitely agree
i see what you're saying but uh it needs
to be done
even when you're training bro you have
to train past
your limits of what you can handle to
make progress to make hypertrophy it
reminds me of when
when i'm waking up in the morning right
to pray fajr
no like let's be honest yes it is
we have to do it but you know there's a
voice in your head telling you you know
what's wasa you just want to sleep you
just want to stay in bed you know
with your wife you got a blanket you got
the heater but
you do it anyway right it's an
opportunity cost but it's one that we
must do
now i feel like in life everything is an
opportunity cost there's nothing that
that could be fully in balance yeah
i do like i do like both of your your
viewpoints
when you say a limit do you mean like
mental limit or physical limit because a
lot of the time with myself
i end up setting a mental limit that's
nowhere close to my physical limit and
that's when i that's when i give in
so i'm curious about that point
did you mean physical you meant mental
right physical bro you met physical
limits
absolutely physically like your muscle
cells your strength your cns can only
handle
some load you must exceed that right in
in working out in fitness we call that
progressive overload if you are not
doing that you will not succeed you will
not progress
that's also it reminds me of the point
mahdi was saying about you're either
progressing or regressing right
right you can't progress to regress i do
understand in a lot of
avenues in life we must facilitate
balance
and restraint for example
let's say anger we must keep our anger
in balance
we cannot go um too much into just
tyranny but we can't just always shy
away and have restraint and not say what
needs to be said or do what needs to be
done
but it doesn't mean that you know we
have to always teeter tatter we we could
be stoic we could be bounced
but in other aspects bro i completely
agree i mean when it comes to
you you're talking about progressive
overload there you see the problem
i will call it a problem the problem
with getting good at something
is that the better you get at it the
harder you have to work
to get even better i'll give you an
example let's say
you f you see your day one at the gym
and you can bench press
uh 60 kilos right let me give it to you
in pounds what's that in pounds hundred
pounds
right hundred pounds that's your day one
in the gym yeah
under 35 pounds right three months later
you finally managed to manage the bench
press 225 pounds
amazing great but guess what if you want
to continue to improve
you're gonna have to go 250 pounds 275
pounds
on and on same can be said for fitness
let's say one day
um you decide you want to um enter some
type of crossfit
tournament okay cool so you start
training for that crossfit tournament
six months later you win that crossfit
tournament then you think to yourself
what's next oh well that was regionals
maybe i should consider
uh county or nationals okay brilliant
you want to go to the national
championships but what does that mean
that means more work more intensity more
pain
and that's the price of progress that is
the cost of excellence
is that you constantly have to be in
your
discomfort zone and the better you get
at something
the higher up the totem pole you have to
climb
it's a never-ending process and if you
take your foot off the gas even a little
bit
well guess what there's no such thing as
maintenance if you're not moving forward
and getting better
you're regressing falling backwards and
getting worse
that's the cost of 100 i do a lot of
online coaching uh for like
bodybuilding and fat loss i have a lot
of clients that come to t3m
and the ones that come to me a little
overweight or slightly obese
and they want to go on a body fat cut
the first couple
weeks are the easiest right then we can
no longer keep
implementing the things that i told them
day one or week one to make the same
linear or at least consistent amount of
progress per week then we have the ante
and i feel like that's that completely
aligns with what you're saying exactly
the same
absolutely absolutely
the uh the kruger effect no
so it's it's not a physical thing like
we're mentioning now but i couldn't help
but think of it when when when you
mentioned it
the effect is essentially when you first
take on a task or try and learn a skill
or you you first do something
like let's say you're learning a new
science right or you're learning a new
sport
your confidence in it initially just
goes like
at a hundred percent and then as you
begin to realize how much more there is
and how much deeper it is your
confidence goes down down until it hits
like
30 and then it slowly goes back up but
it never hits 100 again
you know and i want to build on that
point you just said this panel that's a
brilliant segue
that i can't remember the exact quote
but it's to the effect of
that the enlightened or those who have
knowledge
they are the ones who are always
uncertain about their philosophies
beliefs and so on
but the ignorant remain cocktail of all
of their opinions
100 exactly what you're referring to
there when you have a little bit of
knowledge you think you know
everything once you start pulling back
the cover of the iceberg
and you realize how vast it is it starts
to humble you with its size
and you realize hold on maybe i don't
know anything
you know yeah and there's a hadith where
um
you know it said that allah blocks
blessings or blocks
i guess just uh asking for forgiveness
repentance from those who take
uh participate in bitter or innovation
right the meaning of the hadith
um you know from scholars is that it's
not that you know they don't you know
the
repentance is a block from them or
anything regen is blocked it says
they're so caught up in the innovation
that the the
thought that they're doing something
wrong and that they need to repent isn't
even there
yeah it's not even an avenue of their
actions so
it won't repent and then that's why you
know repentance is bought from them
yes i actually heard recently um
it was a little quote i don't think it's
from a scholar but it said um
essentially allah would not inspire
someone to ask for forgiveness if he
didn't want to forgive them
so it's like along the same line subhan
allah and um
on your point before even imam malik
rahim allah
he said if you are stern in your views
of
then you don't know faith if you're that
permanent you don't even know it
subhanallah subhanallah amazing and as a
segway to that point there
there's a brilliant book um that i
recommend
everyone reads by robert green called
mastery
and he talks about the the process that
is required to reach mastery and there's
one element of the book that resonates
with me every single
day subhanallah and he talks about the
importance of allowing yourself
to remain in a position of doubt on a
particular hypothesis you have formed
about something
he said the longer you can postpone
reaching a definitive conclusion
and remain in that position of doubt the
more
information you can collect on the topic
and the more
wholesome your your opinion your view
your philosophy will become so that
by the time you do reach a definitive
conclusion you're solid
you're like a pillar and that brings me
to a further segway another book by john
c
maxwell um leadership gold and he says
those who begin with certainties
end with doubts and those who begin with
doubts end with certainties
so when you're looking into a particular
discussion point
don't form your don't be too hasty to
come to a definitive conclusion too
quickly
because you're gonna miss a whole bunch
of important information and then you'll
get shown up in a debate or whatever the
case may be and you end up being
like oh i didn't think about that i
didn't see you that side
it's because we reached the conclusion
too quickly so the longer you can remain
in that position of doubt
the better the problem is and i have
found it myself is that
it is extremely uncomfortable doubting
yourself
like you're looking into this particular
discussion point
and it feels really i hope the only way
i can describe it is is that you feel
really
vulnerable you feel vulnerable not being
certain upon something
because when you're certain upon
something you feel secure but when
you're uncertain
you feel vulnerable and you start to
feel like wow man
really i know nothing it's a very
humbling experience
and he's saying the longer you can keep
yourself in that period that frame
and the and collect information from
both sides
the more certain and definitive your
conclusion will be once you get there
it reminds me of how in islam we don't
have guarantee that we're going to go to
jannah
right there a lot of other religions
they do
but for us no we don't we can do
everything we say insha allah we get
jannah and may allah grant us al-jannah
i mean but
we don't have that guarantee and i feel
like that that whole thing you were
talking about about confidence in
reaching something fellas i always say
that
confidence yields um
no competence yields complacency and it
has to do with just when you feel like
you're good enough
you no longer feel like you need to keep
going to the next level
absolutely the moment you feel like you
arrived then you're in trouble it goes
back to our
initial discussion once you get
comfortable once you feel like you've
arrived
you're in big trouble that's why only
the paranoid survive
and that term i love that statement so
much because it can be applied to
anything
including our deen only the paranoid
survivor so what if you pray five times
a day
so what if you give x amount of uh
sadaqah so what if you pray x amount of
nothing
actually we need to humble ourselves and
remind ourselves that us
praying that many times a day us giving
said amount
ask praying extra salawat that in itself
is a blessing from allah in the first
place for having instilled it
in our mind to want to do it yeah
we need to thank allah not just for for
being
able to give we need to thank him for
having given us
the consciousness to want to give in the
first place
because even that is from him yeah um
i mean guys if you made it this far
comment down below right now hashtag
bring maddie back
looking forward to our future episodes
with you i know we're gonna do one on
marriage kind of relationships
networking all that type of stuff
but maybe we might even do another one
on just a theme but i kind of want to go
a little bit into that you mentioned
briefly you have
some type of vagina and i'm familiar
that you know most of us do
we're not perfect but this is not in
christianity where you're going to go to
a confession stand and talk about your
sins
but briefly go over how you kind of came
into it to be the best man the best
muscle man that you could be 10 toes
down
from where you used to be and what
helped you along the way was it more
like
an intellectual thing was it more like
you felt something from allah what was
it um
i mean firstly i thought mostly i don't
i haven't arrived i'm not
you know the ideal muslim i'm far far
from it i think this is an important
disclaimer i need to make
after that i was raised in a
conventional practicing muslim household
my father was very staunch
actually i think maybe how staunch he
was
was possibly the reason i rebelled
against him
he tried really hard with us you know
but i was raised in a conventional
muslim household my father's algerian
and um
you know there was no reason you could
argue for me to have to have gone astray
in the first place
but i did regardless and i did what
you know a lot of kids do alhamdulillah
allah saved me from a lot to be honest
with you because i
didn't have the time i got married too
young
and my journey into practicing islam
voluntarily
happened with my marriage the day before
i got married
i wasn't praying from the night of my
nikkei
at 16 years old to this day i never
missed the salah
allah turned my life around 180 degrees
in from in an hour literally in an
hour period so i went from not
practicing not praying not practicing
not nothing
and subhanallah i abandoned all of the
evil actions that i was involved in at
that time
and i remember the following day because
i was young so i got married on sunday
and on the monday i had a school trip it
is what it is right so there was no
uh honeymoon destination for me i had to
go on this school trip
uh with the psychology department and i
remember
coming we were in a big amphitheater and
it was time for salah it was the winter
time
and the salawat are very close to each
other in the uk in the winter
and i remember coming out and i prayed
in like just in the middle of nowhere
and i prayed and i said to myself wow
yesterday i wasn't praying
today i'm praying not just praying i'm
praying in public where i would have
been embarrassed to do this before
and i realized subhanallah how hidayah
is truly from allah
because that entire process happened
overnight for me
the moment i got married allah put it in
me to want to abandon
all of my evil actions and then start
practicing like a normal
practicing muslim man so yeah
yeah i 100 agree from personal
experience man once you
bro marrying is marriage is literally
fulfilling half of the demon
right so you have four wives that's like
200 percent
of fulfilling a d now that's just a joke
but with that being said
uh it's kind of like the whole excuse
about oh once allah guides me to islam
then i'll start praying
no if you take that step and then you
pray
because oftentimes we don't take that
step out of guilt or
a fear of being a hypocrite oh how could
i
why would i pray if i'm still not giving
up weed or i'm still not
i'm still committing zinna or i'm still
smoking weed or whatever
right i don't judge anyone yeah we
should all you know come to allah
but at the end of the day you're not
praying because you feel guilty that
why would i pray and do this at the same
time no
pray feel guilty because you should feel
guilty and that will bring you closer to
allah insha'allah
i mean that's a good point that you make
that because you remind me of one of the
duraos i sat in by
his expert in phil mashallah one of the
students of shaykh albania
and he talks about this point he talks
about it's a trick it's a ploy from
shaytan
to think that because i'm doing evil
actions i shouldn't pray
no brother i you know i do haram i'm
impure i'm unclean
because i do haram things so i can't
pray he said no on the contrary
is especially incumbent upon you to pray
and then he quoted the verse
the salah is a barrier from fashion
fornication
and evil deeds meaning if you're
involved in evil perform the salah
because eventually the salah will be the
cause
of removing you from that evil but if
you don't pray
then you're definitely going to continue
in it because allah said
it's a barrier from evil meaning it's a
promise from allah
that even if you are engaged in this
evil
if you are continuing to pray your
salawat on time all the time
eventually the salah will be the thing
that actually removes you from that evil
one way or another
man
you got any thoughts yes i wanted to
comment on something
both of you um or one thing for each
uh of you you mentioned before you
mentioned certainty and doubts and all
that subhan allah
and i always heard this hadith of the
prophet where companions came to him and
said we're experiencing these
these huge like horrible doubts of kufur
and the prosthetic said that this is
good news because it's sign of high iman
and i always thought about it like well
if these doubts are
bothering them this much it means they
have high men because you can't really
doubt something you don't really believe
in
right it's only a big evil doubt if you
really believe in it
but now i'm thinking about it from
another perspective that subhanallah
maybe once they
deal with these doubts their amen will
be even higher higher because this
period in which they're sitting in the
doubts allows them
to get more information to be more
realistic and once they
realize again which happens to me a lot
i realize that time and time again the
deen is correct
islam is correct it just grants me this
this
even more firm iman subhanallah and
on the other quote um about always
always being paranoid subhanallah
if you look at um this is a man who was
like the second greatest sahaba
um he was the second uh of the
the four rightly guided uh islamic
leaders right
he conquered byzantine empire and and
persia roman all these places
and after he conquered one of these
places he sat under a tree
and started crying because of how little
he's done for the ummah
subhanallah this is
amanda when he converted the muslims got
to go pray in front of the kaaba again
and you know because you mentioned so i
want to insert an important point
the the topics i was referring to about
seeking
um opinions from both sides of the coin
i was talking to
what you would consider as uh
non-religious affairs well you could
technically tie it to the dean but
different topics like related to my
field for example but if you are going
to
start doing this with the dean you want
you are muslim and you want to for
example
understand atheism i need to put a word
of warning out there to you
and that is this it's a brilliant quote
by a non-muslim
i can't remember it word for word and it
goes as follows he says
a little bit of philosophy will lead you
to lead you to conclude
that will lead you to believe in atheism
a lot of philosophy
will lead you to conclude there is a god
[Music]
so before as a muslim let's say oh i
want to look into atheism
make sure that you are first grounded
fully in your religion
first it's the fundamental thing because
the doubts
the should hurt have hooks the doubtful
matters
they can hook you in and if you are not
grounded in your religion
first you're going to look into this and
think oh wow
yeah maybe there's something there
there's there's a lot of muslims here in
the uk right now
who are studying studying in these ivy
league equivalent universities oxford
cambridge
i know a number of them muslims who have
become atheists
as a result of studying philosophy with
their core degrees
why why is this because they were not
fundamentally grounded in their religion
first
me if i wanted to look into atheism i
would not do that
without first ensuring that i am firmly
planted in my knowledge
comprehension of the deen first so if
you want to
exercise this philosophy that i was
speaking about about remaining in doubt
with your religion
just make sure you're grounded in your
religion first
because the doubtful matters have hooks
and for the lay man i would not even
recommend even doing this
because when it comes to issue of taheed
we're no longer talking about now
winning or losing a debate we're talking
about
jannah and hellfire this is a serious
issue
so unless we are fully grounded in our
religion first
don't even bother entertaining that
because the doubtful matters have hooks
they can hook you in yeah i like that
bro i like that because
we all hear that that saying no thy
enemy yes it's important
without here without learning about
atheism without learning about
christianity without learning about
judaism and all these eastern religions
i wouldn't have had the iman that i have
today the fully man
in islam but it didn't come from me from
doing everything and not having a strong
foundation islam to begin with
right what mahdi is saying is you need
to know your field first knowing
other fields to fully affirm your field
that's secondary
100 agree with that yeah yeah
honestly thank you for mentioning that
because it didn't even cross my mind
because
my journey with islam was i found a
video about islam
and i just got very interested in this
and allah started learning about it and
i found how you know how truthful it is
and
and how you just can't deal with the
claims and the arguments it makes
um and that and that it resonates with
with my fitter alhamdulillah
and then i came across like david wood
and like these these um
apologists and these like islam haters
and all that
and they would bring these very faulty
arguments um
you know i guess i wasn't so much
talking about you know proving
anything other than islam but more so
looking at the attacks on islam that's
that's why i went down
uh like people would say oh the
prosthetist married aisha and she was
this old
uh and you know someone living in this
day and age is gonna feel that's weird
and then
they start studying and looking into it
they break that doubt
and then for me personally my man was
higher but jazakallah
i do appreciate you mentioning that
because
i didn't even realize you know the
implication it could have had so
100 i talked to an atheist when i was
early into my
i guess proper coming into islam
and i remember for that i didn't you
know leave islam or anything but for the
first day
after that talk all i was thinking about
is what he was telling me
and i was like damn i really didn't know
all these things
or another time i watched the david what
video this was for the first time it was
very early into me coming in
i was like oh really looking back i'm
like bro all these stupid arguments they
have they're just debunked but he still
uses these arguments every day
whatever until today i don't know why
but it is what it is man brings in money
the truth has enemies but just looking
back at it if i had that solid
foundation of iman that i have now it
wouldn't have come in iman
not only comes from just feeling close
to allah and all that
it comes from knowledge and
understanding yeah
yeah subhanallah that's true that is
true
um honestly more recently the more i
looked into matters of al-qaeda and
honestly when i read like the original
like the works of like imam abu hanifa
and allah like the the greatest
classical scholars
that alone just like reinstilled this
this really firm eman in me and i don't
know what it was but to everyone out
there
i really do encourage reading like
the quran always obviously but even the
works of the classical scholars like if
you like
um a sick books
honestly if you read that i honestly
think um it will really strengthen
your iman inshallah you all have heard
of a book called disease of the cure is
in there
or disease of the heart and the cures by
evantaemia not sure if you have
i've heard of it yeah it sounds familiar
something on my reading list
but that being said man since we only
have a few more minutes
there's one topic huge topic i know
you're not an expert in it as you said
in your
i think it was an ig live or a highlight
but it's just this whole thing about
pornography addiction nofap all that and
today it's widespread
not only in the non-western cultures but
in the umma too
and you know a lot of people might think
oh i don't want to commit zina
so instead i'm going to do this you know
it's better than committing haram
it's still haram right and what they
don't realize is
it's going to lead to a lot of other
issues physiological manifestations of a
mental
abnormality that i want you to get into
but there's also people
in having wives or having a wife and
they're still watching porn
so what wisdom can you share with these
brothers that are currently suffering
well that's called me of god subhanallah
you know one thing i like to say when
pete when when a brother brings me this
type of question he says to me oh
brother
i had a gentleman bring me this question
the other day maddie there's this woman
at work
i know she's not wifey material she's
she's been passed around like the
village bicycle but i can't help but
entertain fantasies
of being intimate with her what should i
do
and i said to him marry her and he said
to me what
i said marry her make her the mother of
your children
now put a plan in place from this day
forward
to make her the mother of your children
and watch how your own mind will work
against you
to make sure that you don't do that you
see one of the perversities of human
nature is that
we have an inclination to go towards
that which we know we can't
and viktor frankl as i'm actually
quoting him
in one of his methods of therapy he
would implement this thing
so someone with a stutter for it would
come to him and he would say to the
individual
i want you to talk to me but you have to
stutter
you cannot talk to me normally and lo
and behold
the individual would be unable to
stutter anymore
he thought he had some type of mental
disease actually he was
what you try to what you try to do often
because you're trying so hard
you build up this anxiety and you end up
doing the opposite not being able to do
it so i said to this brother
ask her to be the mother of your
children and watch how your mind goes
against you from making it happen to
stop you from making it happen
once you realize the nonsense in this
now when it comes to this issue of porn
what can i say i can give you the normal
spiel which is this
eventually you're gonna become uh the
the biochemical release in your
in your brain will get you to a point
where you are no longer able to look at
your wife
and be stimulated by her your level of
arousal is too high
you want by the way low arousal levels
are what we aspire to have
you do not want a high arousal level a
low arousal level is
mashallah you come home to your wife
even if she's hench she still looks like
a beach babe
right like just low low sensitivity
low sensitivity that's what i'm looking
for when you have a high sensitivity
it means that you need that crazy stuff
in order to get yourself going
so i mean i don't know what advice to
impart other than this
carry on destroying yourself carry on
and have
and see what impact it has on your
relationship because if i say to you
don't do it for this that and the other
reason you already know this
so i say to you carry on have a look
have a seat first hand
what type of damage this is going to do
to yourself and to your marriage
and once you've learned the hard way you
can come back around and tell us tell us
all about it
i love i love giving away these wisdoms
and gems that we're talking about now
because only a select few make it to the
end
you know we all talk about showing up as
half the battle but how many people
actually can have the discipline to sit
through
an actual resourceful video but that
being said i'm going to offer something
a little counterintuitive but it goes
in line with brother mahdi's
aforementioned point
about depression and kind of just mental
illness staying at home
it's forget everything you guys have
been taught uh taught about you know
physiology and just chemicals and all
that and
you know anxiety and you need pills and
all this it all
comes down fundamentally this is just
again i'm not a licensed physician or
anything this is just
what me and angel have anecdotally
experienced and learned through our
limited
time in this dunya so far so bismillah
we all have energy now energy can
neither be created nor destroyed it can
only
be transferred from one form to the
other right
forget cells just think of us as energy
now if we have a high amount of energy
among most of us you know as men we
naturally have high energy
we need to use that energy we need to
dissipate it right a lot of people talk
about sex transmutation right we need to
use this energy
if we don't use it our body will use it
for us
right now think about it like this if
you're sleep deprived what is your body
going to do it's not going to ask you
hey do you feel do you feel like you're
going to take a nap no it knows you
probably pulled an all-nighter
you put the second all-nighter your
midterms what is it going to do it's
going to make you crash
right let's say you're cold it's not
going to ask you hey do you want a
blanket do you want to heat it no it's
going to start shivering to generate
heat right
in physiology we call this homeostasis
or equilibrium it wants to maintain
that balance and it's going to do
whatever it can if we're too hot
it makes a sweat now if you guys ladies
and gentlemen you're not using
this energy that you have your body will
use it
for you what is the most energy using
organ
in the body mahdi what do you think the
brain
100 the brain uses more glucose more
oxygen more blood more energy than any
other organ in the body combined
now think of it like this if you have a
surplus of energy and you're not using
this energy
your body's not going to say hey you
want to use this energy or give you like
a little like
ping like hey reminder use this energy
because it knows we live sedentary lives
stuck for a lot but we do now what is it
going to do it's just going to shoot all
this
excess energy to your brain to just use
it it doesn't care that this
byproduct of shooting up excess energy
is going to be anxiety depression
schizo whatever all it wants to do is
just get you back
into equilibrium exhausted energy levels
right
if we're not doing it first it's going
to do it for us now think about two days
the first day you're going outside you
go to roller coasters you go
you do mma you have to go to the gym
right how do you feel when you come home
matty
exhausted exhausted right but i
guarantee you if you spend the day in
bed
thinking only thinking depressive
thoughts nasty thoughts
insecurities haram thoughts at the end
of that day you will be more tired than
the day where you're actually out there
living very most people would disagree
but if you do it i guarantee you
now the reason being is again the brain
uses more energy than the body
combine that with does a positive
thought with negative thought
burn more energy rami what do you think
negative thought for sure good thought
so now your body's gonna shoot all this
energy to your head
give you negative thoughts too and
before you know it you've become an
efficient energy consuming or burning
machine
it doesn't care about how you feel it
just knows okay we're getting it up
similarly pornography also applies to
this masturbation policy this because
when you're partaking it uses tremendous
energy
to release bro you could create a kid
you could create a human life form
but instead you're just watching a
screen but anyway your body doesn't know
the difference right
so all i know is a lot of dopamine
release a lot of energy release
so you basically get yourself into a
loop where you condition yourself
to live in this low way of life
just to maintain equilibrium of your
energy and we're not even aware of that
subhanallah that's deeper you you remind
me actually when i
when i lived in saudi arabia i was only
there for a year
but i will never forget when i first
came back to the uk after four months to
visit my family i had a very interesting
experience
so i spent four months in saudi arabia
with no wife
and just you have to understand i had
him i had a wife for eight years prior
to that so like man was dying i was
dying
yeah and then i i get a plane from
medina to egypt airport now bearing in
mind the whole time i'm in saudi all i'm
seeing is black
nakab head to toe there's even the
models
if you've ever been there the female
models in the clothing shops
the pictures they're blurred out they're
pixelated so you can't actually see them
do you see nothing in the way that's how
it was back then anyway 2013 i don't
know about now
so you see nothing i get to cairo
airport
and i will never forget the impact one
particular perfume had
had on me it was just a normal woman
spraying a perfume
and it was like a shock to my eyes and i
realized at that moment
that my sensitivity level was extremely
low
and when i came to the uk same
experience three four days later that
effect had worn off
because i'm constantly exposed to these
images
even if you lower your gaze you can't
help but see it once
so to my arab brothers living in the
middle east especially in saudi arabia
they got
their men are firing on all cylinders
because their sensitivity levels are so
low
they're not exposed to it i don't know
about now but that's how it was back
then
um but my point is this generally
speaking no matter where you live
you can still lower your gates
tell the believing man in the believing
tell the believing men to lower their
gaze and protect their privates in that
order
allah didn't say protect your privates
then lower your gaze
he said lower your gaze because that
will help you to protect your privates
so if you have an addiction to porn for
example
the best thing that you can start doing
is just get yourself into the habit of
lowering your gaze nothing drastic
nothing major
you're outside be conscious be conscious
of yourself check yourself okay asura
lower my gaze baby steps slowly slowly
and i'll conclude on this point
there's a brilliant uh arabic proverb
that i learned from norman alican
and he said
whoever makes something big it will
become bigger and whoever makes
something small
it will become smaller the attention and
effort you give to something
will dictate how much it grows or
shrinks
if you make a big deal out of something
it's gonna grow
if you give it very little effort and
attention it will shrink by default you
can apply this to anything in life
where am i connecting this i'm
connecting it to you mentioned to me
what advice could i give to someone who
has this addiction again
i have never had that addiction but i
will say to you this
the more attention and energy you give
it the bigger it grows
the more it grows the less energy and
attention you give it
the more it will shrink and i'll say to
the individual i don't know if i'm
overstepping my bounds here you got a
porn addiction
go even further go on you know you're
destroying yourself
see how far you can take it because now
that you have told your mind to destroy
itself
it will work against you to pull you
back
because we innately don't like doing
what we're told to do
we don't like why why did angel jibril
islam when allah sent him to jannah and
jahannam
he said go to jannah i said allah
whoever sees this will want to enter it
then he said to him go to the hellfire
said oh allah whoever sees this will
never want to enter it
he said now go back again he went to the
hellfire he said oh allah
allah surrounded it with desires he said
oh allah
i fear whoever whoever whoever
i fear that people will enter the hell
fire
because of the shahawat that it was
surrounded surrounding it then allah
sent him to see paradise
and paradise was surrounded with
hardships and difficulties that i fear
nobody will enter in
we work in opposites so if you have an
addiction try this therapy that victor
frankel talks about
you've got a problem do it even more go
further
see how far it can take you because you
know you're on the path to destruction
you know you're harming yourself keep
yourself completely
finish yourself off now your mind will
work
against you to ensure that it starts
pulling you back because you have given
it free reign
you're no longer trying to fight against
this resistance that is pulling you in
you've said okay it's free game i'm
gonna go all in
and watch how your mind works against
you just as that stutterer when he was
told to stutter he said to him
i want you to stutter right now he
couldn't stutter
he spoke freely and normally i don't
know if i've overstepped my mark there
from and episode we're not we're not
qualified to give photos we're not you
know telling you guys to you know
go do more haram right so you know any
mistake we make it's from us in caitanya
but that being said we're talking from a
very theoretical perspective if you guys
want to
abstain from things try overdose therapy
right
you you have a sugar addiction bro go a
whole day just eating sugar
heck go a whole week just eating
carbohydrates you probably lose muscle
by strongly against that but do it
you're going to get sick you're going to
feel miserable by the end of
it your mind will just rationalize bro
how do i just not do it anymore
and you won't get that when you're
tiptoeing around it right and that
that's the difference between having
discipline
and just kind of flailing around and
just trying to avoid things right
this is what means you you completely
can be okay without it
right it's almost like if if somebody's
addicted to alcohol
oh i'm gonna not keep any alcohol in the
house right you shouldn't have alcohol
anyway because we're muslims but if
let's say you're addicted to sugar
i'm not going to keep any chocolates or
junk in the house why
why are you not going to keep chocolate
junk in the house all it's going to take
is you go to your homeboy's house
and he has some chocolates or some
sweets and then you're just going to
cave
or you go outside you go to a restaurant
all it's going to take us that's it
right keep that in you bro wallahi i
have a kitkat bar
on my nightstand i've had that kit kai
bar i think since january
why did i have that it's the same kitkat
by by the way i know my roommate
sometimes thinks like
i eat that and then i replace it nah the
same kitkat bar that that's probably
done as heck right i highly don't if
anyone comes over don't eat that
but that being said why do i have that
there it fully desensitized me
to it i don't want sugar anymore it's
subconscious too people forget the power
of the subconscious mind right
like brother mahdi was saying about the
point go all in
and you'll realize like it's not you
know there's nothing to
it there's nothing more to it it's our
mind tries to shield us away
and give him more power like he's saying
than it deserves and because of that we
glorify it
right we we almost idolize it we hold it
to such a high regard than it deserves
i mean i think that the reason i quoted
norman alexander with that proverb the
arabic prophet whoever
fixates upon something it grows whoever
gives it very little attention it
shrinks when you're trying to leave an
addiction
well i can't speak from a perspective of
experience from what i understand
when you're trying to leave an addiction
let's say you're a smoking addiction
you think about the you think about it
all the time and the problem with
thinking about something is that you are
watering it it's growing inside your
mind
i understand there's like a relapse in
your mind
and your mind is thinking about it but
the problem is you thinking about it
is causing it to grow that's why i said
go on then
destroy yourself finish yourself stutter
and you will not be able to stutter
anymore but i want to be very clear here
i'm not
qualified to give her i feel like this
is stepping into like that was on
and whatever you heard from me please
take it to someone who's qualified
because i feel like i'm overstepping my
mark now
but i get your point man i get your
point it's kind of like people hit me up
all the time right because
again since i'm an online coach they
don't just come to me for fitness they
come to me for everything right
masculinity sleep testosterone whatever
a very common question i would even say
this is one of my most common questions
from any client and non-client
bro how do i fall asleep earlier i can't
sleep i have to wake up in the morning
it's like the more you think about why
can't i fall asleep
you will never fall asleep until you get
over your fear of sleep
or what's gonna happen listen the
mindset i have if i have to wake up
and there's five hours left and i know
i'm not gonna get my eight hours for
testosterone
and i know that i'm not gonna sleep i
don't care if you have the mindset if i
sleep i sleep if i don't sleep i don't
sleep
you will fall asleep faster then why
can't i fall asleep i have to wake up
okay rami anything else no honestly
i've just been sitting back and enjoying
it masha allah i think
they're all really good points yeah man
i don't have fun watching this
yeah that's true sure all right guys
with that being said write down some
some ideas of suggestions for our next
video with mandy
in the meantime before we do schedule
and so
we are prepared for you know anything
else you guys might think would be
valuable
brother mahdi jazakallahu thank you so
much for making the time to be here
i know it's pretty late in the uk right
now i believe but with that being said
i wish you a very good wonderful last
few nights of ramadan
and a wonderful eve insha'allah
it's been a pleasure
all right all right with that being said
for tuning in make sure you watch the
next one with mahdi inshallah
and the rest of our episodes check out
mahdi's book
and his socials i believe he has a
patreon as well if you want to shout
anything out now is the time
to description yeah i'll send it all
over to you inshallah all right perfect
a lot of people have this misconception
that you know once i feel closer to god
then i'm gonna start practicing
it's backwards you won't feel close to
god until you start practicing the
prophet i said
there's a hadith where he says that the
most beloved acts of worship to god are
those which he made obligatory the
person continues to get closer and
closer to allah
key point gets closer and closer by
voluntary acts of good so like sudden
things you know for the sake of allah
things that are not obligatory but you
do them just to please allah
until allah begins to love the person so
two things you want to feel close to
allah you want allah to love you
do what allah prescribes for you which
is
so praying fasting
and then on top of that sunnah prayers
sudden fasts
giving extra charity to the point where
allah will inshallah begin to love you
[Music]
[Music]
hmm